why can't gay or lesbian twins have sex  with or marry each other why is incest  wrong between same-sex siblings well  the reason is because to quote the Great  bioethicist  and philosopher and theologian Norm  Macdonald sex is a filthy shameful thing  that's obviously only meant for  procreation  which is not that answer from Norm is  actually about 85 percent right there's  a little more to it than that  but why well because sex is a very  powerful human thing and so we have this  this institution which happens to be the  fundamental political institution which  is called marriage that actually helps  us to make sense of our sexual desires  and our sexual nature and marriage is  the union of one man and one woman for  the sake of the generation and education  of children and everyone understood this  until about five minutes ago now that's  all gone out the Wayside